Well, back me up for a second, trying to arrange my machine here. It's just freezing up on me right now.
Okay.
Hope you received my deck, right?
Yeah.
And be mindful, the admission happens on its own, so you don't have, you won't be admitting anybody. There you go. Hey, Steve.
Hello!
Hey, Steve.
I.
Good morning, Steve. How are you?
So.
Okay.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
How was the week?
Well, it wasn't good. I was supposed to be visiting my son. My wife and I were going to visit my son and his wife in Myrtle Beach, South Carolina. And about that evening, I ended up
Bhatt.
When we were getting staying overnight in a hotel to catch the plane out, I got severely ill, had to come.
and had emergency gallbladder surgery at last Monday. So never made it to vacation. Instead, I spent my time off recovering from a surgery that I wasn't expecting to have to go through.
Ahh.
Not good.
But starting to starting to feel better.
I.
Okay.
How are you feeling now?
Good, we'll see how it goes.
Mhm.
Sorry to hear that. Feel better soon, please, and in case you need any assistance from us, just do let us know.
Yeah, I'll be good. Thank you, though. I appreciate it.
No worries, no worries. Hey, B.J. Hey, Lee.
Hey, Ajay.
Hey everybody. BJ, good to see you again. Steve, pleasure.
Really?
Yeah.
I believe we can start. Let me share my screen.
Right.
Sure.
Dude, let me know once it's possible.
While you do that, I'm trying to fight with my camera right now. What's wrong with this thing?
Yeah.
No.
As the screen was working.
It is, it is.
Okay, Keith, are you going closer or should I?
Sure, sure, you can, you can. I mean, you can start. I think the initial slides of me, I guess. I'll figure out my camera in a bit. Go ahead.
Yeah.
OK, so yeah, yeah.
Right, the agenda would be, sorry, the agenda would be the check-ins, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap. As soon as I wrap up the dedicated services slide, Barry will continue with the NOC part of the world. You can proceed, Gary, Barry, sorry. Very quickly highlights, Sammy's April MTD billable utilization was sitting at 82.5, which is above the 80% target.
with a standard week of 95% billable in the second week of April. Sammy closed 95 tickets MTD across three weeks, that is from April 4th to 24th, with the latest week of April 18th to 24th seeing 43 work and 42 closed, a near 100% resolution rate. Now this is delivering consistent performance in April. This is for you, Steve.
closing 126 tickets, MTD across three weeks with billable utilization averaging 76.7%, which is almost there, almost approaching the 80% target. That was April, the first week that he worked in, in the month of April, showed 78.1% billable utilization, rising to 79.1 in the next.
week, a positive trend with utilization closing in on the 80% target. Both resources continue to demonstrate reliability in off hours and holiday coverage. Team capability expanding, cybersecurity, hypervisor, and Azure AZ 104 certifications achieved. That's from the highlights front. The next slide would be, go ahead please. Perfect.
the utilization again, starting with Sammy's utilization. This is for the first week.
This is.
There's some, you do not, the slides were not merged correctly, Barry, I guess, because this is showcasing March numbers. There were April numbers shared with you.
Uh...
No worries, I have the mods. I have the mod slides with me. Let me open that. You can continue with the NOC after that. One sec.
Dude, you're embarrassing me, man. What's wrong with you?
Sorry, it happens sometimes.
Yeah.
All right. I think I know what the issue is. The label on the chart at the bottom that says Feb 28th, March 6th or March 7th, the labeling is incorrect. It's basically for the month of April only. I will not go through the chart. I will check why the charts got messed up here. Apologies for that. But I'll really, I'll go through the tables that mention at the bottom. The one
You see right below the chart, I'll walk you through those numbers, starting with Sammy first for the first week of April. The billable hours for him was 30.5 hours. The number of tickets that he worked on was 22. The number of tickets he closed was 20. The second week, the billable hours for him was 38. The number of tickets he worked on was 38. Again, the number of tickets he closed was 33.
Third week, the number of the billable hours was 32.75. The tickets he worked on was 43 and the tickets that he closed was 42. So overall, his utilization varied from 76 to 95 percent across the weeks and month of April. There was a slight elevation in, we can see the slight elevation from week one to week three of April. Total
Total billable hours tracked was 101 hours for the month of April. Again, I think we can move on to the closures for Sammy, if you can move on to the next slide. Yeah, so overall he worked on 95 tickets in the month of April. It included server reboots, AV and backup monitoring, OS upgrades, HTTP checks, NOC alerts, patching.
There were projects that he worked on, Hyper-V migrations, ESXI upgrades, and VDI setup. We'll talk about the first week first. He worked on 22 like I mentioned earlier. He was able to close 20 out of them. The second week, 38, he closed 33. The third week, he worked on 43 and closed 42 in total. So the ticket volumes, it was strong across the month of April.
43 tickets worked and 42 closed. That was the third week, which was a near 100% resolution rate, which I mentioned earlier in the highlight slide. The queue grew from 56 to 78 in week 2 before easing to 75. Active monitoring needing to bring back the backlog down. You can move on to doubts. Ticket volume.
So again, for the month of April, he worked on, the billable hours was 31.25. He worked on 63 tickets in total, closed 47 tickets. The ticket that he worked on was pretty high as compared to Sammy. In the second week, he worked on 55 tickets, closed 40 out of 10. The billable hours was 31.66. The third week.
He was able to work on 53 tickets and closed 39 of them. So 29.07 Bileblavas in total. So Dale's utilization has improved significantly from first week that is 78.1 to the last week, which is 79.1. If I jump on to the number of tickets that he's closed, please jump on to the next slide.
In the first week, like I mentioned, worked on 63, closed 47, second week worked on 55, closed 40, and third week worked on 53 and closed 39 out of them. Total 126 tickets handled, rather closed in the month of April for him. With 63 worked and 47 closed, that was the strongest week for him.
The overall percentage was 74%, the resolution rate that he maintained throughout the month, which is pretty good. Yeah, I see great improvement in his records and his numbers as compared to the previous week. But any feedback for Dale that you have, Steve?
No, I get positive feedback. I mean, I think he's doing a good job and obviously it takes a little time to kind of get, you know, to learn our systems. I mean, he has a lot of technical skill behind him, but just learning the ropes with us. So we've been real happy with his ability to take on more and just kind of a heads up for you guys, one of our service desk
Mm.
Mhm.
folks, Joseph Ruski, he's working through the end of this week on the service desk, and then he actually is migrating into a kind of an Azure Cloud Junior Engineer starting next Monday. So Dowd's going to have to carry a little bit more of the weight at the end of the day. I kind of made him aware of that too, because Joseph...
kind of work, he's been working, he's taken 3 hours off a day the last couple of weeks to work in his engineering role, but he was always back for the last hour of the day to kind of help with service tickets coming in. But as of next Monday, we won't have that luxury anymore. So Dow is going to kind of be the last man standing as far as the service desk goes.
in that last hour to hour and a half, to be honest with you. So I kind of made Dowd aware of that before I was gone. And I was going to talk to him a little bit more about that now. But just a heads up for all you guys, as you know, we it was nice to have two techs work in the service desk until 5 P.m. our time, but it's going to kind of fall more on Dowd's lap.
Okay.
OK.
Mm mm mm.
Going forward to finish the day off there, so...
Mhm.
Okay, perfect. Thank you so much for the context there. So I'll have a better conversation with him today about the same. And I'm sure he... May 4th. Perfect. I was about to ask the date. So yeah, I think it's not a big thing for him. He's used to handling huge amount of workload, so I'm pretty sure it's a piece of cake for him, but still.
Yeah, so, so starting May 4th.
Thank you for the heads up. Thank you for informing him as well, and thank you for the consideration. We'll make sure again he's on the same page. But apart from that, I think last time we connected with Joe, I think he mentioned that there were a couple of servers that were going to be onboarded by the end of this month. I think.
Sure.
Steve, you were not there. BJ, you were on that call, the previous one. Any idea where are we on that?
I think the contract did get signed. I don't, so that part is official, but I don't know the timing of when that's going to occur. I would anticipate that probably is starting May 1st instead of when we'll start onboarding those.
Mhm.
OK.
Is that crossing Rivers BJ or something else?
Got it.
Crossing rivers, yeah.
Is it okay?
Mm.
All right, all right.
So yeah, there should, I would anticipate in the near future, there's going to be approximately 50 servers on boarded. Again, don't know the exact timing. Joe would be better. I see he's double booked for this meeting. So the other thing is, as of May 8th,
Mhm.
I'll no longer be with Dependable, so Joe will be the primary contact as well.
Mm.
Okay, that is 28th you said?
May 8th. So not, yeah, not this Friday, but next Friday.
May 8th. Okay.
All right, all right. Thank you for informing DJ. And I hope we...
So, this is the first, this is the first time you made ITBD aware of this, BJ.
I...
I don't know if Joe had before.
Okay, I haven't talked to BJ in three weeks either, just so you guys know. So this is my first day back.
I was on vacation for two weeks and then Steve was supposed to be on vacation for a week. Sounds like that it goes planned.
So BJ, I got a lot of catching up to do on things, but yeah, so okay, so now it's official with ITBD, we didn't know.
Yeah.
So you didn't know as well, Steve? Is that what he's saying? Oh, okay. All right.
No, I did know.
Steven, yeah, yeah.
I was like, whoa, okay, that, okay. Well, I mean, I hope we connect before you leave, Steve. Sorry, BJ. I think we've been... Sorry, sorry. That was... So I hope we connect before you leave. I'll definitely set an alarm and connect with you.
I was at work.
Hello.
Anyway, what?
Yeah.
Trying to force out Steve? Come on.
Okay.
a day before your last working day, PJ. We've been working together for a while now. It's been years. So yeah, not a very happy moment for me, but yeah, it is what it is, I guess. So we'll definitely connect.
For sure.
No, it sounds great, Keith. Yep. No, just so, I mean, just in the loop, I'm actually not going anywhere else at this point in time. I'm taking a couple of months for myself to try to figure things out. So leaving on good terms with Dependable on everything. I don't think Dependable's in a bad place per se, any of that stuff. So just so you guys have a little bit of that context too. So.
Okay.
Perfect, okay. Good to hear that. Good to hear that, Vijay. Right. I think we're good on the dedicated side. You can jump on to the NOC piece, Barry.
Thank you, Keith. Yeah.
And just an FYI, I think Joe is already informed of Sammy's son. He's diagnosed with pneumonia, so he's currently in and out. He's, I did ask him to take leaves, but you know the guy, BJ. So, but still, I've told him to just keep me updated in case he needs leave. And Joe is.
informed about the situation as well. So in case we need any assistance, we let you guys know.
Well, yeah, and for sure, I mean, we'll reiterate with them too. But yeah, I mean, family's more important. The job will still be here for him. You know, much more concerned about people's well-being than the work. So.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you. All right, over to you, Barry.
Thank you. So the agenda for today for NOC side will be the highlights and summary. The SLA summary, the patch compliance, the backup compliance, inventory true up and recaps and to do if any. Let me move ahead to the highlights piece. Key highlights.
for the month of April were high volume of P1 infrastructure incidents, primarily server offlines, tied to power issues and patching activities and ISPs as well. Strong cross-team coordination between ITBD, dependable solution, ISPs and the client IT teams as well. Patching cadence maintained across multiple clients despite independent access and credential constraint.
I believe that was already resolved, but yeah, there wasn't any restraint for the month of April, but yeah, for the month of March, I believe there was, so just keeping it there. Client trust remained intact with frequent acknowledgements and positive feedback, post resolutions. When and successes, rapid recovery of those.
aforementioned server offlines within hours of escalation. VPN access has been set up for I believe eight of the clients. I did work with Joe, not Joe, BJ and one of the network guys as well to get that set up and workflow.
Like Joel hadn't raised the concern that the tickets weren't getting resolved, the closed which were resolved, so we had set up a workflow to close all those tickets as well, when if they are in the resolved status for more than an hour. For an end account access is also available now, which we worked on alongside the VPN access. Last scale up April page patching, I'm saying paging, I'm not sure.
Patching computer across education, finance, and manufacturing clients with minimal residual risk.
Issues, risk dependencies on ISP outages, creating multi-client downtime with no ETAs, disk alert misalignment. This happened in the beginning of the month, I believe. A few of the fragmentation tickets were passed on as disk space, so the configuration had been changed.
And Sameer, I believe, has completed the work on it. And the alerting for fragmentation alerts for SSDs has been removed and for VMs has been removed as well. Learning and improvements, again, alert for this fragmentation for all VMs has been removed and will only be available for physical servers.
Any questions, Steve, BJ?
No, I think we're good.
No.
Thank you. Moving ahead for the SLA slide. For the P1s, we received 26%, 26 tickets, and 100% resolution response SLA was met on all 26 of them. We received 22 P1 tickets, all of which 21 of them met the response SLA. One ticket got missed out. The ticket was assigned to an engineer on time, but yeah, the...
acknowledged when it wasn't hit, so the halo, like the PSA, like marked it down as not being acknowledged. But yeah, the ticket was assigned on time and worked on time as you see the 100% resolution rate for those P2 tickets. For P3 tickets, we see a total of 27 tickets, and again, 100% resolution and response rate for all 27.
For P4, usually schedule maintenance tickets, patching and whatnot, we received 13 tickets and all 13 of them have like 100% response and resolution SLA.
Okay, any questions regarding the SLE side team?
Nope.
Thank you. Moving ahead.
to the patching slide. As of now, we managed 21 clients and 136 servers. I believe two of another servers for SOC prior are being decommissioned. Like, Sushant did send out a message that those two servers were off ported, and I believe we would be removing those as well as soon as we receive those emails.
But yeah, as of now, they are setting at the 84.25% compliance rate. It is a bit low as the patches were released later and the first Sunday, second Sunday, clients were missed out on the April patches. So yeah, once in the upcoming month, their cycle comes again, those patches will be installed.
So, the number will go higher.
than 84.25.
Moving ahead to the backup slide.
Again, 21 clients managed for backups, 136 server count, and we did receive only 10 tickets for backup failures for the clients. Like we did receive one for Dodgeville, one for Meister Cheese, one for JRM, three for Warnwalk and four for PDC, and all of them are successfully completed.
Backups are running at 100%, so the backup compliance is also setting at a good green 100%.
Any questions regarding the patching and backup side thing?
Nope.
Okay, thank you. Moving ahead. Regarding the inventory, this is currently setting at 136 servers. No Plex, the two Hyper-Vs which were really like removed last month, so it's currently setting at zero, but I believe so.
Prayer would also go down to two, like they'll go down to seven, but yeah, as of now, we are sitting at 136 as per inventory that includes 3 hosts on 133 managed servers.
And moving ahead to the to-dos, Keith to confirm the regarding the upcoming onboarding action plan. I believe Keith, you just did, yeah.
We just discussed, yes.
Yeah, and I just messaged Joe to ask what the timing of that is so that we can let you guys know too.
K.
Yeah, OK. Any uh to do from this call team? I think we want this like ITBD to take care of.
I don't think so.
I don't have anything.
Okay, I guess I'll mark this one also as closed. Yeah, moving ahead. These will be the informational slides, the services we provide, the business locations, one in US, three in India, and one in the Philippines.
your dedicated resources, that is your escalation matrix, my manager Keith to his manager Gary to Sameer to Javid as a Dio. I'll open up the form now and then share my screen. Are there any questions for this call team? Anything on your end? Anything on the mind?
I think we're all good from defendable say.
Agree.
OK, OK, anything from your end, Keith, Lee.
You're on mute, Keith.
Since Keith is muted, I'll go ahead and jump in. Oh, Keith, go ahead.
Yeah.
I was just saying I'm good. I was about to ask you Lee if there's anything you'd like to share.
No, I didn't get to say it when you shared the announcement, BJ, but best of luck with everything. And I'm glad you're getting time to do whatever head clearing or whatever next looks like. I know it's uber important, so good. And please don't be a stranger.
If.
We're already connected on LinkedIn. I double checked when you said it. So please, yeah, please tag me, tag me, whatever, and I would love to catch up again soon.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Yep.
Well, no, I appreciate it guys. Really loved working with IT by Design. You guys definitely made my life easier and that was important.
Sweet.
Appreciate it.
Happy to help out.
So BJ, you don't have your consulting business cards created yet. Is that what you're saying? Still debating that.
Yeah.
No, I haven't created a lot of plans, Steve, as you would know.
Bye.
Yes, yes. Thus the sabbatical, right? No plans.
Exactly. Well.
Mhm.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, gentlemen, I believe this is it then for today's call. Everybody have a great day ahead and bye-bye for now. We'll meet ahead. Thanks so much.
Thank you.
Perfect, thanks guys.
Thanks for everything you and your team does. We appreciate it. Bye, guys.
Thank you, everyone.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bhatt.